静かに地元に帰ってきました
こちら富山県。僕の実家なうでございます
半年ぶりにちょっとゆっくり
実家で出来る時間がなんとかできました
少しなんですけど
しばらく富山にいれそうなんで
と、言いたいとこなんですけども！！
今日はですね
ちょっと１つやってみたいことがありまして
こちらの
「モバイルバッテリー」
使ったことありますでしょうか
父ちゃんも母ちゃんも寝てるからさ
静かにやるね
開けてみましょう
あっ。ちなみに弟も寝てるよ
実家だとね、その、みんな寝てるからさ
静かにやんないとダメなんすよ
おお
こんな感じでございます
ここ押すと
充電ができると
こちらに挿す場所がございます
ここからモバイルバッテリー自身を
充電できて
こう挿すと
この先から
いろんなね、スマホとかポケットWi-Fiとかに
充電できるというものでございます
俺は考えた
そう！
このモバイルバッテリーさ
こう普通に充電できるわけじゃん
でも、これだけだとさ
やっぱ充電できる限界があるわけです
そこで私は
ガタガタッ
こちらにたくさんのモバイルバッテリーを準備しました。
おれは思っｔ
でぅふっふっ
おれは思ってしまった
このモバイルバッテリーで
僕のiPhoneを充電しますと
これは分かりますよね
モバイルバッテリーで僕のiPhoneを充電します
で、この充電しているモバイルバッテリーを
他のモバイルバッテリーで充電します
こう、こう、こう
こういう感じです
スマートフォンをこのモバイルバッテリーで充電しますが
このモバイルバッテリーを
このモバイルバッテリーで充電する
もうこれはね、我ながらに天才だと思った。
このモバイルバッテリーを
このモバイルバッテリーで充電して、さらに
他のモバイルバッテリーで充電する
そして、この他の充電しているモバイルバッテリーを
さらに他のモバイルバッテリーで充電する
そしてこのモバイルバッテリーを
そして、さらにこのモバイルバッテリーを
さらにほかのモ...
モバイルバッテリーを繋げてるだけで
無限にスマートフォンが運転できるんじゃねーか
買ってきたモバイルバッテリー全部開けます
こいつらを繫げましょう
マックス充電なのかな？
一応ね、マックスにはなっているんですよ
マックスってことは、たぶん二時間くらいなのかな？
一個二時間だと計算すると
８個あるので、１６時間
そして僕のiPhoneは
残り充電が17%
まあ、１６時間＋これが１００％になるとすると
ま、２４時間かな？
ま、２４時間くらいは持つと思います
間違いない
いまから電源つけっぱにしますから
電源つけっぱなしにして
２４時間持つとかなりいい方だと思うんで
モバイルバッテリーでモバイルバッテリーを充電し合って
スマートフォンは何時間持つのか
検証していこうと思います
おれは実家に来て何やってんだか
ピンクのバッテリーを
あなたが充電する
で、そのあなたを
で、そんなあなたを
あなたが充電する
はい、どうでしょうか？
一応全部光ってるので
やる気はあるみたいです
充電かなり少ないんですけども
ま、僕が起きるころにはマックスになっており
さらにまだ、全然動いてるイメージだと思います
ちゃんと全部ついてるからね
OK, OK, OK, OK.
では、僕は今から
寝るんですけれども
32000mAhのモバイルバッテリーですよ
ビリビリバンバンバン
さあ、この32000mAhのモバイルバッテリーをバックに
僕のスマートフォンはどれだけ持つのでしょうか
じゃあ僕は寝ます
えっと、電源は落ちないようにしてあるので
常に電力が消費されます
よーい、スタート
はい、始まりました
ちゃんと全部ついてるからね
OK, じゃあ、おやすみなさい
次の日の朝
信じられない光景が、目の前にあった
ハゥ！
なんで
なんでぇー(泣)
あんなにモバイルバッテリー接続してたのにぃー(泣)
(ガタッ、ドン)
あ゛ぁ
ウゥ～～～～～～～～～～(泣)
ハーァッ
ウア゛ーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！！
(扉が開く音) うっせーー！
ごめんなさい